winning top honors in the dark
i'm sorry i'm drunk winning top honors
in the documentary category this year is
director liz che with her film the last
mermaids
it was
it was also made at columbia university
and documents the women of jeju island
in korea for over 2 000 years these
women have turned to the ocean to give
them life
shield them from war and educate their
daughters please welcome gold medalist
liz chay
thank you so much
this is such an honor um
i'm wearing a new pair of shoes so i'm
i was going to return them afterwards
because they're so expensive but i think
at this point i'll just keep them
um this is such an honor i wanted to
thank the academy for hosting all the
winners and watching all the films
it's just amazing it's such an honor to
be one of the winners among
all the all the films from all the
different schools and also from the
other uh from
cassie and uh
oh my god i'm so nervous oh my god from
the weight uh from a place of land it's
just an honor to be
to be part of the documentary category
with you
ever since i was little
my
i grew up in jamaica and in new york
city and
my parents are korean and they shared
their stories with me of their korea so
that was my link to my heritage and
um
and uh they introduced me to you know a
whole host of different characters and
they lived along the seaside and they
share them
their war stories and uh their stories
about these henyasis uh
women's sea divers and and i'm trying
not to be so nervous um
they uh
when i had the opportunity to go to
columbia
um
studying at columbia gave me a chance to
pursue my directing and to really find
my voice and that's when i reconnected
back to the stories that i grew up with
as as a young as a young girl and
i had the opportunity uh through a e um
a in columbia gave me a grant
and kind of gave me the seed money to go
out to jeju island to
to live with these a group of these
women and to follow the story
and uh it was amazing meeting them
and they
they taught me that
that
through their will to sort of change
their circumstances and to
to better their lives and to better
their community and the world around
them that uh you can pretty much do
anything and be your own hero
and that uh they kind of share that with
me that you know it's possible for me to
also create my own dream and to form a
community and and to believe in that
um i would like to thank again the
academy and the board of governors and
ase for just having such amazing um
events and hosting us and
i would also like to thank again a e uh
for giving the seed money to to uh to
make this film possible
and also the the five years i spent at
columbia university film school
specifically my mentors nick perfaris
maureen ryan and david jones who passed
away uh last year
um for inspiring me to really focus on
finding my stories and my voice and to
pursue that and let not nothing stop me
and uh of course i would love to thank
my
my crew
and oh
one of the things one of the
collaborations that happened also
through columbia is the ascap columbia
music workshop and
that workshop gave me uh the opportunity
to meet my composer who did the music
which is amazing
um joel dueck and through that
collaboration we were able to create
uh this this world and bring it to a
much higher level so i would like to
thank asgap and joel dewick who's here
right now with his wife gabby
and i'd like to thank my crew
jesse whitnall who's not here my
associate producer my underwater
cinematographer and uh
my um
my
dp day and kim who could not make it
and uh
my friends and my classmates from
columbia who just shared and and working
with me through the whole editing
process and
lastly uh my mom and dad could not make
it my dad is uh wasn't able to make the
trip but um they're in new york and
they're gonna be really excited to hear
this great news i would love to thank
them for
just being there for me encouraging me
and and sharing their stories with me so
thank you
you